trois enfants empoisonné à l'arsenic
dans la vallée de l'eure biel dans l'eau
une pollution déjà constaté dans les
eaux du département dans les années 60
ce professeur lançait la nerthe il est
certain que 2030 scène d'arsenic soluble
par litre d'eau rendrait une eau
inconsommable est susceptible
d'entraîner des accidents pathologique
la mine d'or de salsigne dans le
département étaient déjà pointés du
doigt l'exploitation tournait alors à
plein régime depuis 1892 chaque jour 5
kilos d'or pur ont été extraits à celle
ci une activité minière aux multiples
déchets toxiques tous rejetés dans l'eau
reviennent une rivière de l'autre qui
traverse douze communes du département
dans les années 90 la pollution
s'intensifier avec des boléros et g mais
l'activité aurifère est un vivier
d'emplois dans l'aude le président de la
mine se voulait alors rassurant en
europe nos rangs dieu prend que nous
pourrons acheter l'environnement mais
les rouges est chargée en métaux lourds
persiste dans la vallée de l'orbiel de
l'arsenic du cyanure
mais aussi du soufre dans l'air en 1996
le maire de la commune de conques sur
orbiel dénonçait une situation
intolérable qu'on ne fait que peu plus
l'industriel que les services chargés de
se respecter réglementation maîtrise ce
dossier et ce sont les usagers quel chez
michel kunz eagles de nouvelles analyses
sont alors effectués
un an plus tard les résultats tombés
attention danger
salade toxiques la préfecture de l'aude
vient d'interdire la commercialisation
et la consommation humaine des légumes
cultivés dans cette vallée un arrêté
préfectoral toujours valable aujourd'hui
en 2004 la mine d'or de salsigne ferme
définitivement ses portes
mais les déchets résiste dans
l'environnement en 2006 une étude
révélait même un nombre élevé de cas de
cancer des voies digestives ou
respiratoires dans l'aude ce riverain se
sentaient floués
on n'a pas été prévenu en temps et en
heure et que la vérité au rip déjà à
être plus ce savoir et être divulgués à
partir de 1997 1998 si les pouvoirs
publics avaient eu la ronde
aujourd'hui la vallée de l'orbiel elle
fait partie des territoires les plus
pollués de france une pollution aggravée
à chaque intempérie ou inondations
[Musique]